[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis vraiment ravi de
passer les 18 prochaines minutes avec
vous et aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous
parler des résultats de mon travail de
recherche bien sûr mais j'ai aussi envie
de partager avec vous l'intérêt que je
trouve dans la recherche fondamentale et
dans le métier de chercheur en
neuroscience cognitive
alors sans doute vous vous demandez déjà
comment je suis venu à la recherche en
neuroscience cognitive bon lorsque
j'étais au lycée g mais la philosophie
j'aime et les mathématiques
et puis j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à
la recherche sur le raisonnement la
perception à penser en général et donc
j'avais vraiment envie de faire des
études dans cette direction mais il
n'était pas vraiment évident de savoir
comment arriver à ça et en terminale
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer albert
jacquard qui m'a dit vous voulez faire
d'un fils au fait des maths
vous voulez faire de la biologie fait
des maths voulait faire de la recherche
sur le cerveau fait des maths alors j'ai
fait des maths et puis j'ai intégré le
département d'études cognitif de l'école
normale supérieure enfin là quand même
je vais m'arrêter quelques secondes
parce que sûrement comme moi vous sentez
le paradoxe de cette altercation
bon c'est comme si donc quel que soit ce
qu'on souhaite faire il vaut mieux
commencer par étudier les mathématiques
en l'occurrence pour moi ça a marché
j'ai fait des mathématiques et puis je
me suis tourné vers les sciences
cognitives et donc ça serait comme si
les mathématiques était une sorte de
principe fondateur de langage universel
et pourtant on ne sait toujours pas
comment la pensée mathématique à émerger
est ce que c'est une forme de pensée à
part entière complètement indépendant du
langage d'ailleurs qu'est ce que c'est
que le langage est ce qu'il ya plusieurs
types de langage
est-ce qu'on peut même imaginer une
pensée complètement indépendant du
langage et puis si les mathématiques
sont vraiment un principe universel
comment se fait-il qu'ils aient autant
enfants à l'école qu'ils soient
traumatisés par les mathématiques et
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait remédier à
ça alors voilà les questions
s'enchaînent
ça devient presque vertigineux et je
crois que c'est ça qui m'a vraiment
motivé et intéressé dans l'idée de
comprendre comment ça vous fait des
mathématiques puis je crois aussi que ce
vertige
c'est une bonne description du travail
de recherche et heureusement on peut
s'appuyer sur la pensée de tous ceux qui
nous ont précédés qui ont posé et
creuser la question avant nous et en
l'occurrence la question de l'origine
des mathématiques remonte à l'antiquité
est encore aujourd'hui le débat qui
anime les philosophes et les
mathématiciens c'est celui de savoir si
les objets mathématiques existe dans le
monde de manière indépendante de
l'esprit humain
c'était d'ailleurs l'objet d'un livre
récemment coécrit par le
neuroscientifique jean pierre changeux
et par le mathématicien alain connes
mais alors du coup si les objets
mathématiques sont un produit de
l'esprit humain qu'elle est vraiment
leur nature et puis quelle est leur
relation avec le langage est alors sur
cette dernière question le linguiste
noam chomsky nous dit et prétend que les
mathématiques émergent comme conséquence
de nos capacités de langage
et puis à linverse albert einstein lui
quand on quand on lui a demandé de
réfléchir à ses propres mécanismes
d'invention a dit non pour moi les mots
et le langage ne semble joué aucun rôle
dans le mécanisme de ma pensée alors
voilà en fait c'est ça mon travail mon
travail c'est d'essayer de répondre par
l'investigation scientifique à des
interrogations que l'homme se pose sur
lui-même et en l'occurrence dans mon
domaine
ça passe par la réalisation
d'expériences afin de déterminer si les
mathématiques sont universelles et 6 et
quelle est leur relation avec le langage
de nombreuses équipes de recherche qui
sont pensés sur le plancher sur la
question déjà et qui ont notamment
étudié les bébés parce qu'il ne maîtrise
pas encore
le langage est notamment dans une
expérience fondatrice dans les années 90
cette expérience dont kkr et jean a
montré que si on prend des bébés de
quelques mois qu'on leur montre un objet
qu'on cache cet objet et qu'on ajoute un
second objet et qu'on enlève l'écran est
bien les enfants
après quelques mois de vie sont très
surpris de voir apparaître seulement un
objet alors qu'il s'attendait à voir
deux objets dont finalement c'est très
simple expérience tend à montrer que les
enfants ont déjà un sens du nombre et un
sens des opérations arithmétiques
élémentaire et puis hein
une collègue et ami a aussi montré que
des nouveau-nés d'à peine quelques
heures ont déjà un sens du nombre assez
prononcée est assez abstrait en fait
elle l'aurait les a habitués à écouter 4
ou 12 sons et puis elle leur a montré
simultanément 4 ou 12 images et
finalement ces bébés de quelques heures
se montrent plus intéressés lorsque le
nombre de son et d'image sont les mêmes
que lorsque le nombre de sans aide
images diffère donc sa s'attend vraiment
à montrer qu'il ya déjà une abstraction
du nombre que quelle que soit la
modalité finalement visuelle ou auditive
la l'information numérique est
importante
et puis il ya également eu beaucoup de
recherches menées chez de nombreuses
espèces animales parce que les les
différentes espèces animales non
humaines sont non pas de notre
typiquement notre langage par les
humains et notamment beaucoup
d'expérience ont été réalisées ou
certaines expériences ont été réalisées
en milieu sauvage penser à cette
expérience menée par une équipe
italienne qui ont enregistré les cris de
différentes yens puis ensuite les a
joués à proximité de groupe deviennent
sauvage ils ont pu observer que la
réaction des hyènes s'adapter en
fonction du nombre de cris différents
perçu donc typiquement lorsque le nombre
de yens de la fausse note en approche
était évalué comme étant inférieur au
nombre des hyènes présent dans le groupe
et bien là il se préparait à attaquer et
à linverse lorsqu'elle estimé leur
nombre inférieur au nombre de yens de la
fausse note en approche là elle fuit
donc finalement ces félins montre une
certaine capacité à évaluer et à
comparer des quantités et puis s'il ya
bien une espèce qui a particulièrement
été étudié pour ses compétences en
numérique dirons nous ce sont les singes
les primates
en réalité il est assez frappant de
constater que leur capacité à approximer
des quantités et a comparé des nombres
est très similaire delà de notre
capacité humaine à le faire il ya
également une équipe japonaise qui a
montré qu' on peut apprendre à des
chimpanzés a associé des quantités avec
des symboles numérique et ces chimpanzés
sont même capables après apprentissage
deux classés dans l'ordre croissant ou
décroissant ses symboles et même
lorsqu'on en soit certains noms
typiquement si vous leur montrez 7
et si vous présentez 7 et 9 mai pas à 8
ils sont quand même capable de classer
dans l'ordre croissant ou décroissant
et puis finalement j'avais aussi envie
de vous parler de ses expériences assez
exceptionnelles qui ont été réalisés
chez une population qui vit en plein
coeur de l'amazonie les modes de recours
parce qu'ils ont un accès très faible
presque pas d'accès ou même pas du tout
accès à l'éducation et ils sont
particulièrement intéressants parce que
leur vocabulaire ne comprend pas de mot
pour désigner les nombres exacts
et pourtant même en l'absence d'un
vocabulaire spécifique
ils ont une vraie aisance à manipuler
des quantités donc dans cette expérience
on leur présentait une boîte dans
laquelle on introduisait un certain
nombre de fèves puis plus de fèves et
ensuite en leur demandant s'ils
estimaient qu'il y avait plus ou moins
de fèves dans la boîte que dans un autre
tas de fèves à côté de la boîte là leurs
compétences dans la réalisation leurs
performances dans la réalisation de
cette tâche sont tout à fait similaire à
c
des adultes français et donc quand j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser à la cognition
mathématiques en 2010 je me suis plongé
dans toute cette littérature et venant
moi même d'une formation de maths
pouvait imaginer que j'étais un petit
peu déçue de constater que la prendre
majorité des expériences déjà réalisé
porté sur les nombres et l'arithmétique
parce qu'au contraire les mathématiques
comme vous le savez tous
c'est enfin cela recouvre un grand
nombre de 2,2 de domaines et de
disciplines différentes comme l'algèbre
l'analyse la topologie la géométrie qui
potentiellement font appel à des
compétences multiples et donc j'ai eu la
chance d'être admise par stanislas
dehaene dans son laboratoire avec l'idée
de d'étudier la manière dont le cerveau
manipule des concepts mathématiques de
haut niveau et lui de son côté je crois
que ça faisait des années qu'ils avaient
envie de revenir à cette thématique de
recherche est donc finalement on s'est
lancé pour mon doctorat dans le projet
un peu fou de scanner des mathématiciens
professionnelle en irm fonctionnelle
alors l'irm fonctionnelle
c'est la composante neurosciences du
travail si vous voulez parce que c'est
une technique d'imagerie qui permet de
manière complètement dans invasives de
visualiser le cerveau en action et donc
j'ai proposé à des mathématiciens
professionnels dont trois mathématiciens
non voyant une série d'expériences en
irm dans laquelle ils ont écouté des
affirmations mathématiques et non la
thématique dont il devait juger la
valeur de vérité alors vous imaginez la
scène vous prenez un mathématicien vous
l'allongé dans l'irm vous le bombarder
de questions et en essayant de rester le
plus immobiles possible de répondre et
vous faut en appuyant sur des boutons et
donc j'ai réalisé trois expériences
différentes avec des haches formation
différente dans la première expérience
j'ai proposé des affirmations
mathématiques de très haut niveau
alors je vous faire écouter matrice
carrés sur un corps équivalente à une
matrice nippo tentes sont les matrices
non inversible imagine que vous avez
tous compris que c'était une phrase
d'algèbre vrai il existe un groupe
d'ordre infinie admettant un nombre fini
de sous-groupes là il fallait bien su
répondre faut dans cette première
expérience j'avais aussi quelques
phrases qui n'avait absolument pas de
sens comme celle ci peut te variété
algébrique localement contractile est
contenue dans un hyper beau louis
domingue et puis des affirmations non
mathématiques pour contrôler tout ça qui
nécessitait le même niveau de réflexion
et de combinaisons d'informations telles
que celle là en grèce antique un citoyen
incapable de payer ses dettes devenues
des esclaves
voilà dans une seconde expérience j'ai
proposé des alternatives plus simple
mais qui a impliqué différentes
stratégies de résolution donc par
exemple a + b au carré est égal à akkar
et plus bigarrée + 2 ab alors là si vous
vous souvenez de vos cours de maths
c'est normalement parker sa 2x moins
trois facteurs de 2 x + 3 égal 2 x carré
- 3 là on a un exemple de calcul
algébrique racines de deux fois et
hippie sur quatre est égal à un plus
alors pour répondre à cette affirmation
je vous assure qu'il faut visualiser le
sarc trigonométriques dans votre tête
parce qu'en 2 2,5 secondes
j'y arriverais pas autrement et c'est
aussi le cas pour ce genre d'affirmation
sinus 2x moins pis sur deux est égal à
gossip music ce et puis enfin j'avais
proposé des affirmations de géométrie
dans un triangle équilatéral ellipses
tangente au milieu des côtés est un
cercle et puis toujours des affirmations
non mathématiques qui servent de
contrôler un harpagon est une personne
caractérisé par sa bienveillance
finalement dans une troisième expérience
j'ai proposé encore des affirmations
plus simple mais cette fois ci au niveau
de leur grammaire de leur syntaxe comme
celle ci par exemple certaines quad rixe
on déconne et donc vous entendez qu'il
ya incertaine dans cette phrase puisque
l'objet de cette troisième expérience
était d'ajouter des opérateurs logique
minimaux comme des quantifie catr ou
même délégation certains mammifères sont
des cétacés alors là c'est la version
avec quantifie catr non mathématiques
attend une négation le groupe des
translations n'est pas commutatif et
puis éventuellement même une combinaison
de quantification et de négation
certains élus phare ne sont pas des
plantes aquatiques
voilà donc finalement ce que j'ai pu
observer en ayant proposé tous ces types
de phrases à trois différents groupes de
mathématiciens dans une irm
c'est que pour toutes les phrases
mathématiques
quel que soit leur niveau de difficulté
quel que soit le domaine mathématiques
étudier quelle que soit l'expérience
visuelle des participants on observe une
activation vraiment reproductible des
mêmes there un cérébral que vous voyez
en fait sur ces trois images en bleu
c'est vraiment c4 c4 erre ici qui sont
les sillons intra pariétaux qu'on a ici
et puis des régions inférieur temporal
on a ici et c'était assez frappant c'est
que ces régions coïncide avec des
régions cérébrales qui répondent à
l'arithmétique et à l'espace
elles sont complètement dissociés désert
qui sont classiquement associé au
langage al'inverse pour toutes les
affirmations non mathématiques qui
portait sur l'histoire la géologie la
faune la flore tout ce que vous voulez
même quand ces affirmations n'ont
mathématiques comprennent des quantifie
catr ou dénégations là on n'observe pas
du tout les mêmes activation une
dissociation complète même puisque vous
voyez ces activations envers ici
représentés qui sont beaucoup plus
classique mancelle lié au langage donc
une dissociation complète entre les
affirmations qui contenaient des
informations mathématiques et les
affirmations qui comptait des
informations et
en mathématiques donc finalement ce que
tend à montrer mon expérience mes
différentes expériences
c'est que les mathématiques de haut
niveau recycle en quelque sorte des
aires cérébrales qui sont très anciennes
au sens de l'évolution et qui sont
impliqués depuis longtemps en
l'évolution dans l'arithmétique dans la
compréhension de l'espace et au
contraire les mathématiques ne repose
pas sur les compétences de langage donc
en pratique on peut imaginer que peut
être enseigné les mathématiques en se
fondant sur quelque chose de pyramidale
avec a beaucoup comment dirais-je de
manipulation d'objets et puis en fondant
des nouveaux concepts sur des concepts
beaucoup plus basique pourrait être une
une bonne méthode d'aproz cela dit on a
encore beaucoup d'expérience à faire moi
même je suis encore en ce moment on peut
stocker en train de les essayer de
tester des hypothèses et savoir à quel
point le langage intervient dans
l'apprentissage des deux concepts
mathématiques nouveau mais en tout cas
c'est typiquement à ce moment là où les
gens me demandent en général mais au
fond à quoi ça sert tout ça et j'espère
que dans les le quart d'heure qui vient
de s'écouler j'aurai réussi à vous
montrer que la recherche fondamentale
c'est essentiel au développement de
l'homme dans sa quête de connaissances
dans le développement la société que la
recherche fondamentale quelque part
c'est comme le creuset dans lequel se
forgent les applications futures
en l'occurrence pour moi les
applications concernent d'apprentissage
et vont vers des questions qui traite de
l'intelligence artificielle ou bien qui
ont trait à l'éducation et on est en
train de développer des nouvelles
hypothèses de nouvelles à clarification
de nouvelles idées autour de techniques
pédagogiques peut-être qu'ils vont
ensuite être testés à nouveau par
d'autres expériences en sciences
cognitives
voilà je vous remercie de votre
attention
[Applaudissements]